you're looking at a creature few humans
have ever seen this is the krusty
Nautilus just never before been a film
and hasn't even been spotted since 1984
and we see here that it immediately
shows its greatest weaknesses cages and
fingers yet it has a way of escaping
things like fingers and hungry mouths
covering its shell is a sort of skin
that feels like wet mops scientists
believe this covering helps it slip away
from the grasp of its predator now I'm
willing to venture the already know
about the Nautilus
we have beautiful shells that are
striped like tigers and have short
little tentacles indeed they're
cephalopods so they're related to other
tentacled sea creatures like the octopus
and squid but instead of actively
hunting like other cephalopods the
Nautilus --iz are largely scavengers it
spend the bulk of their time on the sea
floor searching for dead fish to eat and
good on them for that they can do
whatever they want with their lines as
for the crusty Nautilus it's definitely
still a scavenger but unlike other non
slimy speeches of Nautilus it shares a
habitat with it doesn't scrape the
bottom of the barrel that is the
seafloor instead the crust will make its
way up the water call following reefs
into shallower waters here it will find
even more kinds of dead fish on how the
incredible biodiversity of the reef but
this migration is not without its
problems more biodiversity means more
predators and more predators means more
bull and this may well have been what
filled the evolution of the slimy shell
with more predators to worry about and
without the safety of the darkness of
the deep the krusty would do well to
have an extra slippery countermeasure so
it's become the closest thing the sea
has the Slimer from ghostbusters only
without all the screaming and bad
attitude it's got that going for it
which is nice